now this question here maybe some of you
went through it because it's early in
the exercise and didn't bat an eyelid
but there's a lesson to learn here a
couple actually so I just want to focus
on it even though it's a remarkably
simple question okay we want to
differentiate this log function and it's
not just log X simple log X and nothing
else it's got a tiny little adjustment
here it's X divided by 2 now there are
two ways to do this question I'm going
to show you both in a second first I'm
going to start you off with the way
that's a little sort of a scenic route
okay the scenic route is our X onto is
not just regular X it's a it's a
function of X I've done something to it
so therefore one of my instincts is I
guess I could use chain rule on this
right it's a function of function log of
that's a function X on 2 that's also a
function ok now I remember because I
wrote it down about 40 minutes ago that
the derivative of the log of a function
has a pretty nice easy law to remember
out of it it's a fraction what's on the
numerator f - very good and then on the
denominator f of X ok F - on F because
you'll very quickly get tired of saying
on of X now have a look here this is my
f of X in here the guy inside there
that's f of X so X on - that's 1/2
multiplied by X what's F - in this case
it's just it's just 1/2 that's what's
going on going on the top of my
numerator okay you can see even though
it seems a bit overkill I put brackets
around this 1/2 can anyone tell me why
I've done that what's going to go on the
denominator it's going to be f so on the
numerator I have a fraction on the
denominator of a fraction fractions on
fractions you're asking to be confused
or to communicate not very clearly
because we don't always write a nice
long fraction line vinculum in the
middle of an exam we rush so this is
completely unambiguous we know what this
is okay there is the derivative I can
write this simpler though can't I what
would you like me to do to the top and
bottom let's take the top and bottom and
multiply both by
that'll get rid of all my fractions so
that leaves me with one over X now at
this point I'm a little perplexed
because I know the function that I
should differentiate that gives me 1
over X that's like a really important
basic function and it's not this guy
right the function that I differentiate
the primitive of 1 over X is just it's
just regular log X right without any on
2 without any weird other stuff in there
that's what's supposed to get me to you
well it does get me to 1 over X so why
does this also get me there okay hmm
have a look at this for me here is log X
okay now this is a good opportunity to
note that the derivative of log X is 1
over X but with an asterisk on it
whether terms and conditions apply
because 1 over X exists in some places
that log X does not you see that there's
a domain restriction on this what is it
X is greater than 0 right but 1 over X
exists for X is less than 0 as well okay
so we actually should put that now's as
good a time as any
you won't um you won't lose marks for
not writing this but you should write it
because it actually makes a difference
we'll come back to this point later on
this thing only exists here so therefore
it's derivative only exists there as
well makes sense now what of x on to
what does that look like well that's
what it looks like now just engage your
visual mind for a second and work out
with me what is the difference between
log X and log of X on - ok now on a
first look just a first glance to me my
brain thinks that the red graph log of X
onto is the black graph but moved to the
right that's what my brain thinks like
it looks like to me ok cuz like I'm like
look there there there there
it sort of makes sense right but there
is a reason a visual reason you can look
at that and you can know that that is
actually not what's going on it has
not moved to the right this is not a
right positive translation a horizontal
translation it's a vertical translation
can you want to tell me how just looking
at the picture not worried about algebra
or laws or anything like that how can
this picture convince you that you have
not moved to the right at all you've
actually moved down can anyone see this
graph is missing something isn't it
right if I were to actually submit this
is like an answer if I went back to log
of X then a really important feature of
log of X is the fact that it has an
asymptote right by the way in case you
didn't know sorry bear with me x equals
[Music]
desmos can do dotted lines so if your
fan seen all that kind of thing you can
hardly see it on the projector which is
a shame but anyway there is my asymptote
for log of X and you can clearly see now
bless you that log of X on 2 has the
same asymptote you notice that so for
example just imagine you if this is 1
and this is 2 which it is if you were to
do one unit to the right okay then the
asymptote should come with you it should
also have gone over right but it has not
look it just blows straight through it
right if it were there and you can see
there are other reasons why it's
inconsistent it's not one unit to the
right here that's not it one unit right
and neither is this for that matter okay
so there is no horizontal translation is
only vertical now how can we show this
using what we have over here this was
the scenic route this is a long way of
doing it there is a simpler way and this
is something that Ari and I were talking
about before an overall principle it's
just so important it's worth writing is
even though I hate the word I'm gonna
use it anyway because it's the only one
that fits in this context it's rather
than going straight to calculus
straight to differentiating if you
possibly can simplify first then
differentiate I'll give you a really
obvious example of this okay I have to
use the word simplify even though I
dislike it because
you have to apply this to a broad range
of different functions for which
simplify means different things so
here's an example if I gave you this is
this what I gave you Eric I remember
something like that okay if I gave you
this and I asked you to differentiate
not a trick question as it's written
right now what rule must you use to
differentiate this you must use the
quotient rule because it's a question
yes and you'd go you and then you give
me and then you start going and then the
Sun sets and you're like I don't want to
do it this way I don't have to write
this as a question I can simplify before
I start differentiating yeah what
knowledge would I need to use I could
factorize there's an e to the X here and
I can take it out of the numerator right
I'm even simpler than that I can just
start canceling right without having
factorized e to the 2x divided by e to
the X is going to be just e to the MU
key indices it's gonna be X right what
about this guy you can be left with e to
that 3x right no questions inside and
this is like this click the easiest
thing to differentiate this is fine okay
simplify then differentiate now how
would you apply it to this if I said to
you okay is there something I can do
with this before I actually launch into
calculus what would you do
think back to your log laws look
carefully
see see that X onto C excellent when you
divide inside there that's called the
argument by the way it's very seldom
using this context but that's what it is
when you've got a fraction there in the
argument you can break this one log into
two now usually that's a Messier thing
usually having two logs is inferior to
having one log right it's longer the
right but do you see how in this context
it is simpler do you see it what's the
derivative of log X 1 over X what about
this minus log 2 what does it do
it shifts it vertically right it's gone
downwards log2 so remember how I showed
you when you go across you're like oh
it's a different shift all the way it's
not a horizontal shift at all
okay look carefully if you can watch
through here look at the vertical
distance do you see the vertical
distance always the same always the same
it's always log - I think it's like 0.67
so I don't know it's it's a small amount
okay so this is what's happening it
doesn't contribute anything to the
derivative so tada
I'm finished okay does that make sense
so I wanted to point out you know if you
look at something here don't meet like
your sign to learn more you're like I'm
gonna use laws cool but but pause for a
moment we try and avoid the question
rule everywhere we can so you guys are
quite good at that now but other ones
are not so obvious it is not because LOD
laws are something that people are
historically banner it is not obvious
that you should manipulate this with log
laws before your differentiate so I'm
trying to actively get you to look at it
now okay